last year Alberto Fernandez never
thought he could become Argentina's next
president he was a rival of former
President Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner
and even though he was her husband s
Turkishness
chief of staff he was also a fierce
critic of her time in office now Alberto
and Cristina as people call them have
put their differences aside together
they have a better chance of defeating
center-right president Mauricio Macri in
Sunday's vote I told Cristina let's do
it together and let's do it right let's
do it together and show the best team in
Argentina as this one the one that
thinks for Argentines four years have
passed four years of pain of seeing 43
small companies shut down a day
thousands of people without work
regional economies our pensioners
suffering salaries dropping all that
happened were the government that filled
the pockets of the banks on Thursday
Alberto Fernandez closed his campaign in
the city of Mar del Plata where his
puranas party stood together for the
first time in years president Mauricio
Macri closed his campaign in the
province of Cordova knowing polls show
he's running behind by at least 15
points Macri has been struggling with an
economic crisis that has put Argentina
on the verge of default once again he
blames the previous administration of
Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner we are
going to have to continue facing
challenges to solve but bringing the
same ones from the past will not help us
at all let's not fall into the promises
of those who led us down so many times
for so many years they ruled for so many
years and left the country in tatters
for months people here have been
withdrawing their money afraid that
Argentina's banking system may collapse
once again just like it did in the past
political and economic uncertainty are
making people turned
the US dollar and that's why the central
bank is using foreign reserves to
prevent the further devaluation of the
peso currency that immediately
translates into more inflation there's
lots of speculation on to whether the
government will be forced to implement
further measures to contain the
hemorrhage of the foreign reserves
Alberto Fernandez says mcLeese agreement
with the IMF to introduce austerity here
is to blame and Mauricio Macri is now
promising to end spending cuts and push
for growth his challenge is to convince
voters to trust him one more time
terasawa al Jazeera Buenos Aires